everybody was going on play here and I'm
backstage with the lovely gray spot
[Applause]
stuffy your audience in here you have an
awesome voice amazing soulful I think
it's been described as what are some
good vocal warm-ups you do do you
specific yeah every day before you get
going one good warm-up is a rubber baby
buggy bumpers rubber weights in a slope
rubber baby buggy bumper rubber baby
butt rubber rubber baby buggy bumpers
you just see that a thousand times just
kind of get it just like loses that
rubber baby buggy yeah you just keep
going until you spit on me you're gonna
be on vh1's storytellers
is there anything too hot for vh1 yeah
yeah really actually they played a
really funny joke on the head of our
record company and they sent him what
what they said well here's the promo and
there's this one thing I said there was
a point where I had like a frog in my
throat
you didn't ear know I obviously hadn't
warmed up in that right it was like a
really serious song and in the middle of
a serious song I was like oh this is
what I get forgiven bloated comes before
I go on sick and what they did was they
cut it into like a really pro looking
vh1 promo and sent it to the head of my
record company they're like what do you
think about this that's amazing and what
was there a heart attack immediately
no he I think he's smart enough to know
what it was but it was just genius
genius jokes - oh cool so we got some
questions from the old Twitter you're
huge on Twitter I know that Grace Potter
grace Poe huge I have like you know like
50 someone the store looks nice don't do
that
how many followers you out my dad I
actually check it a lot I'm in 10,000 43
and I'm like bleeding slowly so it's
like every time I make a tweet I lose
like three followers it's true
it's really true no anxious kitties and
you will get just put some up there yeah
I should probably stop the naked
pictures at Angel and white ass what is
your favorite song off the lion the
beast and the beat to play live man
that's so hard right now it's the lion
abuse the beat that song is it's an epic
thing it's got pieces of it it's got a
hole it's got movements like I said
there's airplane landings there's like a
lot of this now I'm starting to learn
the songs yeah cuz the crowds just
getting to know their new music that's
great
if they can already figure out that it's
fist-pumping time about halfway through
it's like it's really exciting and get
people jumping up and down mr. brito
says what's your favorite cheese oh
that's easy
come on mr. burrito it's Kabat habanero
it's the spiciest most amazing cheese in
real Cabot cheddar have an era are you a
big cheese person major holy crap did
you just roll that right up that's easy
oh my god but I also love like Jasper
Hill Farm I mean I'm from Vermont right
he's a big thing absolutely but we
actually work with Cabot Creamery oh my
god yeah we we had a Cabot bus for a
while we had like a cheese bus and they
sent us on the road cheese and no one
took a crap for like bucks last question
I juggle Lopez say says has your hair
grown back you burned a good piece of it
on at a rock stars huh that's what this
tweet says and tweets are never wrong
obviously listen I was right though I
did burn my hair off it was bad it was
really really bad well it's about right
oh my god then it was some and so I had
these bangs covering up and then
everyone started getting bangs so I was
like oh yeah exactly
princess all right Grace Potter
everybody the album the new album the
line of the Beast the beat is out now
iTunes and stores get it grease Potter
calm at Grace Potter on Twitter vh1
storytellers what else what else can we
plug this one time it's plug Sam all
right grace Potter you rock you rock
thank you so much good talk see you guys
next time
[Music]